I loved it I thought it was very clever
and that the advertised the ad at the
end was a kind of coder that allowed it
it allowed you to to rewrite the end in
whatever way you wanted to interpret the
end of the story the way you wanted to
and you could have the your version of
Don Draper whichever one satisfied your
narrative I mean you directed an episode
of this particular season did you know
at the time how the story was going to
end I had the opportunity to read
episodes twelve thirteen and fourteen
but I didn't want to I I wanted to watch
the end of the show the way I'd watched
the first two seasons so I turned down
the opportunity to read those scripts
and at you you'd hear little rumors and
stuff about ideas that were being
floated and some of them happened and
quite a few of them didn't because if
the story was in flux towards the end
but yeah I wanted to experience it the
way I'd experienced it originally so I'd
be sat in the edge of my seat wondering
what was going to happen and you know
like we were saying earlier dear that
that opening shot of Don Draper behind
the wheel of the car looking like
someone out of the Wacky Races or Mad
Max which is just fantastic I was
thinking a lot of people's mind what
really stood out as well as the fact
that you know Don Draper came
full-circle many of those around him a
one or two exceptions had a very upbeat
ending to their story unlike your
character do you feel a bit upset by
that no I I I wasn't there in the
beginning so it was perfectly fair that
I wasn't there at the end and also um
you know I the the way that he he wrote
me off the show was so dramatic and I
wouldn't have been nominated if he
hadn't have written me out that way so
you know I I it was at the time when he
told me that was what was going to
happen I had conflicting feelings about
it because on the one hand from an
actor's point of view I could see it as
his incredible opportunity I was very
excited by it but from a life
experienced one of you I know I knew at
the time
that this was a very very rare set of
circumstances and that I wasn't going to
walk off the set of madmen and find this
experience somewhere else again but he
didn't walk away you came back to direct
I mean how did that happen and he ends
up directing one of the most iconic
episodes as well of the final season
which mirrored some of the ones that
you've been in earlier that was complete
serendipity I was supposed to do an
episode in the first half of the sea of
six season seven but I was doing a movie
I think poltergeist up in Toronto and
that had we were we were going over so I
wasn't able to to do the pre-production
so he bumped me to the second half and I
just ended up with that particular
episode but it was a fantastic episode
because it had all these sort of strange
resonances to the last episode of a
season three shut the door and have a
seat how important is sort of
understanding the style the tone when it
comes to making madmen very important
and I think that's the reason why he
trusted me with it and it was an
incredible that act of faith that he had
I mean you know it was it was like he he
let me drive his sort of custom design
1969 sports car offered for two weeks
and trusted me not to put any dings or
dents in it you know but I'm the
everyone who's been walking working on
the show for the seven seasons they know
what the show is and you know what it
isn't and my responsibility chiefly was
I'm not going to tell Jon Han I have got
no insights into his character that he
doesn't have and it would be insulting
of me to even suggest something like
that my responsibility was to to remind
them of the narrative because I had the
script for three or four weeks before
they got it they got it the day before
and I read it 50 times and they read it
twice so my job was to was just about
story constantly to focus on the story
I'm looking back now across those seven
seasons what is a legacy of Mad Men I
mean arguably it's changed television I
think that long-form
drama scripted drama was was warm I was
gone I mean after that Sopranos there
wasn't a lot of it around and suddenly
you know you've got it on Netflix you
got Amazon people are hungry for it
you're not that desire is not really
being fed in the cinemas any longer and
that desire for that kind of nuanced
entertainment and storytelling is being
supplied through television so you know
in some ways it's almost replaced the
novel you know drinking jarred house
it's been fantastic talk to you thanks
for joining us thank you